in reality Democrats have a terrible
track record when it comes to race and
equality and the rights of human beings
for example this morning congresswoman
AOC Alexandria ocasio-cortez asked
Senator Ted Cruz to explain the history
of the democratic party Crews responded
quote first it was the Democratic party
that founded the KKK it was the
Democratic party that wrote Jim Crow
laws then the Democratic party was the
one that filibustered the Civil Rights
Act add to this our current President
Joe Biden he was working to stop the
integration of public schools because he
didn't want them to become quote racial
jungles those were Joe Biden's word
words and he partnered with the former
Grand Puba KKK bird as Cruz also pointed
out today Biden also gave that
passionate eulogy at the former exalted
Cyclops of the clan Robert KKK bird who
his mentor as he called him at the time
and now Democrats are attempting to use
race what a shocker they do it every two
years every four years as a divisive
semi-marxist political stunt dividing
this country you know black versus white
old versus Young Rich versus poor just
divide any way they can generalizing
certain races has Perpetual victims
others as evil oppressors now here's
South Carolina Senator and presidential
candidate well Tim Scott take a look
I do think this is a difference in how
we communicate there's no question that
my life disproves the lives of the
radical left their culture of victimhood
is eating away at the soul of America I
understand Brokenness I understand
having low esteem I understand nearly
failing out of school but I also
understand that we do not live in a
nation of grievance we live in a nation
of greatness
now I want to compare that thoughtful
intelligent message to Joe Biden's pitch
to African-American voters take a look
you decide
you got more questions but I tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're familiar Trump and you ain't
black
there's your president anyway so
congresswoman ocasio-cortez uh are you
proud of that are you proud that you're
president the guy that you look up to
that leads your party try to stop the
integration of public schools he didn't
want them to become in his words racial
jungles do you endorse that message or
do you think that maybe it's time for
the Democratic party to finally move
away from its racist Tendencies and
candidates who once supported
segregation and praised as their mentors
former klansmen anyway let's give a warm
audience welcome uh in studio tonight
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
well that was a
that was a great exchange with AOC oh
look it was uh
she asked if I was willing to engage I
don't think she wanted the answer to be
yes and I will say one of the stunning
things for the little socialist from New
York
she hadn't said a word in response uh I
don't think there is a response that was
too big you know by people may not know
this Alan dershowitz has said and you
disagree on a lot of politics but he has
said you're one of the smartest students
that he ever taught you were the number
one debate champion in the country when
you went to Harvard Law
um
I think this may be deep waters for AOC
and I got to tell you in college really
it was very effective at a party with
girls to say Hey you know I'm a college
debater it really would that that went
over well yeah yeah you know you know
your kids are division one athletes I
was a debater so you know it's it's
similar listen it's something to be
proud of all right let's look at 2024.
yeah okay uh DeSantis tomorrow yeah Tim
Scott got in the race Trump leading in
the polls where do you see this going
you you've been through this I was with
you all throughout 2015 and 16. you you
you went the longest and came down to
you versus Donald Trump how do you see
this race look it's going to be Wild and
Woolly I will say do you think it's a
bad sign for Joe Biden
when Hillary Clinton is saying he's old
and corrupt I think that was set on
purpose and I think I think that the
Democratic establishment
they don't want you yeah
[Applause]
tweak that a little bit six months ago I
said I didn't think Joe would be the
nominee
um
I now think he's likely to be the
Democrat nominee
because I think the Democrats think
Trump is going to be the Republican
nominee and I think the way Democrats
think they think okay if Trump's the
nominee they can hide Biden in a
basement for two years and just run on
how much they hate Trump I think that's
their strategy I think if at any point
in the coming months Democrats suddenly
think it's going to be anybody but Trump
I think they'll throw Joe to the curb
and try to find someone younger because
Joe at this point the guy can't tie his
shoes without assistance no well I would
argue he doesn't know today's Tuesday so
um you know but this is going to be a in
my mind it's always about peace and
prosperity I think elections okay about
the future
can you think of a single thing that he
has done that has benefited the American
people because I can't and the question
if it's asked properly are you better
off now than you were four years ago
look I'll frame it even more simply is
there any aspect of public life that
doesn't suck more than it did four years
ago but like it really is spectacular in
our entire lives have we seen a
president screw the country up more in
two years than Joe Biden like everything
is worse domestic economic foreign
policy like like it has been
let me ask you a question seriously Sean
imagine you you'd be the host I'll be a
guest all right
I like that that's good all right
imagine you sat down with the objective
I want to destroy America
what would you do differently than Joe
Biden's done the last two years
nothing
I mean I mean when you think about this
what bothers me and what frustrates me
is all of these problems to me were
preventable yes we had a secure border
we know how what an integral part of our
economy is related to energy yeah we
have all these natural resources we were
energy independent we could be providing
Western Europe with all of their energy
needs and we'd be paying down the debt
by the trillions over the years yes uh
and stop robbing from our children and
grandchildren I am very concerned China
sees Joe's weakness for four seasons of
course and sees it they've now formed
what I call new axis of Evil you see
that absolutely look Joe inherited a
situation that was potentially
phenomenal he's our president I would
have liked him to succeed you take
something like the Border he inherited
the lowest rate of illegal immigration
in 45 years all he had to do was do
nothing continue the same policies and
he could start with something that no
president has had prior to that
inheriting the great successes of the
Trump Administration he came in and
immediately screwed it up you know you
have said
every state is now a border state yes
and by the way if you may not remember
in the middle of the pandemic if it
wasn't for you because we couldn't get
our TV cameras in there were cages with
kids piled on top of kids that were
overcrowded in the middle of a pandemic
we're not doing any background checks
we're not seeing if people have radical
associations we weren't even doing
health checks there was no vaccine
mandate for illegal immigrants by the
end of this year it's going to be seven
and a half million illegal immigrants
just since Joe became president
so when I went down to the Border this
is early on in the Biden Administration
they had the Joe Biden cages filled with
kids
and at the time Fox News wanted to embed
a cameraman to come in with me I brought
19 Senators with me you had a big group
to see this
and the Biden Administration said no
we're not going to let the fox cameraman
in because the cameraman might have
covet
was literally their justification and
and mind you they had there was a
massive rate of coveted positivity in
the cages and so as you noted I pulled
out my cell phone and I just filmed it
and sent it to you we would not have
known had you not sent that video to me
and there was a little political
operative from the Biden Administration
it was standing in front of me yelling
at me she was sent down from DC to stop
any photos or videos of what was
happening she kept yelling
respect these people respect their
dignity and I said look you respect
their dignity you're the one that are
locking them up in cages you're the one
that are sending them to be with human
traffickers you're the one that are
letting the women be abused and the kids
be brutalized and the Biden
Administration thrives in darkness they
trust the corrupt corporate media never
to report on their disasters and what
you do and a handful of others is just
tell the truth let's talk a little bit
about the debt ceiling yeah
um there are now 44 Senators if you
include Senator Kennedy I don't think
he's signed but he told me that he's
standing with the 43 of you so the least
colorful thing John Kennedy's ever said
true I use one of the more humorous guys
in the center I love John he's a good
friend and he's genuinely Hysterical by
the way all right can I tell you my
favorite John kennedyism he said if Adam
and Eve had been from Louisiana yeah
they'd have been Marie and Boudreau
and they'd have thrown out the apple and
eaten the snake
that's that's Senator Kennedy great job
um so we have the debt ceiling
um Joe Biden disappeared for 97 days I
argue he made a bet the BET was
Republicans in the house won't get a
deal done yep okay they got it done by
the way I think a great deal go back to
2022 spending levels yes cap the the
rate of growth to one percent Baseline
budgeting uh add in some energy measures
which we need desperately it's it's
scored by the CBO to save 4.8 trillion
dollars the Senate is standing with the
house yes okay I don't think Kevin
McCarthy needs to budge look and if
Biden wants to default it'll be Biden's
default let me praise I think House
Republicans have handled this
beautifully and I can tell you in the
Senate so Senate conservatives we met
every week we would sit down with house
conservatives and we'd say listen our
role in this battle is to back you up is
to have your backs is to encourage Unity
what we wanted to avoid is any wobbly
GOP Senator is suddenly jumping ship and
joining with Administration we haven't
had any we've seen Republican Unity
something that doesn't happen very often
and you're right Biden was counting on
House Republicans not being able to get
their act together and his position of
go pound sand I won't negotiate I won't
talk about it was so obviously
unreasonable that he gave in I'll give
you an amazing stat
58 percent of Democrats believe we
should have significant spending cuts as
part of the debt ceiling Joe Biden is
the left of his own party and I think
we're going to end up I hope and believe
with some real positive steps to rein in
the lunatic spending that's in
Washington let me ask you let me go back
to 2024 for a second yeah
um look I've been there an election yeah
there's an election and by the way his
re-election is critical it we need you
in the U.S Senate we really do
and Lenny
let me say on that front Chuck Schumer
has made my race the number one target
for a Democrat pickup in the country the
last race I was in they outspent us
three to one they're going to flood a
hundred million dollars into Texas and
so I want to take a page out of our
friend Lindsey Graham's book and say
please go to Ted Cruz dot org Ted Cruz
dot org Ted Cruz dot org because we got
to stand up to the lunatics
so in in any primary there's always
going to be at some point is going to
get contentious yes it was it came down
to you and president Trump you guys kind
of remain friendly to a point then it
just happens did it get a little hot it
got a lot hot
um but this race is starting out hot
yeah yeah between the president and and
Governor DeSantis I wish that would
happen later yeah if need be it may not
even need to happen
um because the real problem in this
country are the left wing yes look you
and I are both friends with we respect
president Trump we respect Ron DeSantis
I I I think very highly of both of them
when When Donald Trump was President
there was no senator who worked more
closely with Donald Trump than I did in
the U.S Senate Ron DeSantis I think has
done a phenomenal job as governor of
Florida I'm proud of the job he's done
as Governor Florida by the way the fight
with AOC that you started your monologue
with
it started with the NAACP idiotically
putting a travel warning for going to
the State of Florida because they said
Florida is unwelcome to African
Americans and AOC chimed in and and and
said and agreed with it and I said look
Florida
African Americans are moving to Florida
in massive numbers because it's an oasis
of freedom and your party has a terrible
terrible record on Race we're going to
follow your race we're going to support
you in your race uh we love having you
the only bad decision you made is
leaving Texas to come here
um but everything else you're doing is
great Senator great to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else